hey everybody I'm Tiffany Smith and I am
Kristian harloff I'm very excited we are
joined by Will Arnett he is the voice
all right now I'm just gonna correct you
he is Batman Batman one of the talented
actor was playing Batman once again in
Lego the Batman movie will thank you for
joining us thank you very much for
having letting me come in here so nice
and cool in here so far this is my
favorite place at Comic Con this room
well we just met see how it goes and
then I'll say after yeah well we do have
the air conditionings actually I would
say Fandango studio we win yeah we'll
just leave it at that yeah no need to
explain what I love so much obviously
it's just hearing you talk your register
is so low it's kind of perfect for
Batman and I've gotten to talk to some
other actors who voiced Batman like
Kevin Conroy and they always have to be
really serious when they're doing the
character but you get to have a lot of
fun with this character that's my fits
it's my favorite thing to do bi I think
it's because all the other guys have
been so serious over the years that you
know it's kind of unfair I get to just
goof around and and it kind of works
like we we found a great sort of balance
and a great sweet spot with with Batman
in the first lego movie so it's a real
advantage advantage for me to be able to
do that well you mentioned the first
lego movie
was there any time when you were voicing
the character Batman you said you know
what I could see this kind of standing
alone as a standalone movie I'm a dumb
guy so I just start there I did not see
that happening so when they told me you
know we found out the day that the lego
movie opened and it was kind of doing
well I never resolved excited and they
were like hey we're gonna make a we're
gonna make another lego movie but we're
thinking we're gonna make a Lego Batman
movie what do you think and I was like
well yeah yes but yeah like I was
totally thinking that well it's
interesting because they went it became
so popular character is so funny in the
way and obviously a voice that when they
announced it cuz I know they were gonna
do a lego see well first yeah and then
they pushed up Batman
yeah come out because it's so popular
people want to see it was that kind of
crazy awful yeah I mean I was excited
I'm not entirely sure you know I'm not
privy to all the machinations of how
that kind of stuff those decisions get
made but I was definitely in you know I
was very enthused that we got to kind of
but it but our place in line a little
bit and get the movie out early because
I think it's really it's a really fun
movie and I also gave you know everybody
a chance to to really work on the second
lego movie and that's much more
comprehensive than you bring a lot of
different stories together for that for
this from moment one I think they had a
pretty clear idea of what they wanted to
do how cool is it for you to get to see
the Lego Batman minifig and you're like
that's me it's cool yeah it's cool I
mean I actually have on me the new right
yeah he just came out today you don't
want to touch him because I had him in
my mouth from your mouth to your pocket
I love it I know most hygienic dead
packed the Deb Gibson Patrick's who's
watching right now says she loves your
Lego Batman voice oh well is that a
question I don't know Gibson Patrick
well thanks Dennis Gibson and Patrick's
three people three people now they all
said she loves you're like oh they
finally came together to make that one
of the voice though like a lot of times
when people do voice over they kind of
have to develop what the voice is gonna
sound like but talking to you like I
said earlier you already have that like
low register is there anything you do
differently when you are Batman well
yeah I mean you know when Batman is a
little more he's much more than here you
know it's almost like a gravelly whisper
and so you know when we record and and
you know you do things where he's kind
of doing that voice but yelling it's
it's it can get rough yeah on the old
vocal cords well were you doing so was
there because you got to do kind of
hairiness sometimes if you look at
something like what Jared Leto is now
doing for Joker he when he looks like
he's doing very different from what
Heath Ledger was doing but for you is it
almost like a parody of like some
Michael Keaton stuff and it's not so
much parody like I look I I had the
benefit of a lot of Batman before me
that I could go back and reference and
look at and take you know your reference
you mentioned Michael Keaton I love
Michael kids my favorite he was the
first one yeah I love that dude he's a
great actor and an all-around cool dude
so you know that was but I got to kind
of pick and choose the things you know
take we all know who Batman is he's very
iconic character I could take those
rules and bend them a little bit so it's
not really as much a parody but just I
could also sort of play with the idea of
why he is so lonely we've always seen
him as dark and brooding and all these
things right now we got to get into why
yeah Harley asked how would Lego Batman
fare against Jared Leto's Joker very
well very well then Joker would just put
Lego Batman in his mouth and crush them
with those metals he looks a little is
kind of scrawny yeah we're saying it's
kind of more like a punk-rock Joker
yeah like or just Punk kind of like
skinny and like kind of like frail just
kind of like hipster yeah the wiry ones
but in a good way in a good way by the
way in a good way but it looks amazing
it looks really cool I'm just singing a
fight right yeah an actual thing you
look you look super rad and that movie
looks super rad yeah incredible
I'm have you seen it yeah no no no no
but the hype for that movie right now
yeah it is so anticipated we can't wait
for you I want to go on record saying
that that movie's gonna be a hit I know
but and Will Smith
there's nobody cooler than Will Smith
well not that we should compare Lego
Batman to any of the characters because
they're their own separate things but
the Joker doesn't have a theme song like
Lego Batman
true will we get to get any new songs
darkness no we might we might have many
things yeah okay we'll see we might all
right Josh asked do you actually like
Lobster Thermidor you Josh I can't I
can't divulge too much I don't want Josh
I don't want people to know how the
sausage is made right it's fair no
that's fair
a lot of people want to get too much too
much behind the scene I don't want to
give away too much history yo Josh
you'll never know if I like Lobster
Thermidor unless you go forget her with
me and there's Lobster Thermidor our
only Lobster Thermidor on the menu and
then you'll have this you'll see me make
it to see well speaking of make you
making you make decisions we've got a
little game we want to play with you
okay would you rather oh man we're gonna
go through this game is never good for
me but okay go ahead would you rather
have Lobster Thermidor with Josh or have
lobster are you really paying me in a
corner all right will do would you
rather have a face like a pumpkin or
body like a tennis racquet a great
question would I rather this is the
question I've been avoiding my entire
career would it rather this they
recently took it off the SATs face like
a button or a body like it bother you
like a tennis racket I'm gonna say face
like a pumpkin I guess you could get
roles in movies because there's a lot of
horror films that's right and then I can
yeah regular body is my point if you're
functioning body just from a tennis
racket that's are not quite sure where
the head goes on the tennis racket
and where's all that everything else
should mix if you're just tuning in
we're here with Will Arnett we're
playing would you rather and I have one
right now okay would you rather we're
doing another head question have I have
a grapefruit-sized head sure or have a
watermelon sized head but I'm gonna give
you a why why what are we interest what
these crazy what's with the head
replacement I thought it was gonna be
like would you rather like you know be
with the the grip or be like what else
don't avoid would you rather make out
with the camera dude or like lick that
the skeet ball game head like a
grapefruit or head like a watermelon and
is it the size or is an actual the size
he says yeah the question is grapefruit
sized head okay okay I already have a
pretty big head it's quite big it's yeah
it's shockingly big it doesn't look at
at first glance the jaw fits them yeah I
thank you you know you're good dude
thanks i would say head like a because
if you had like a grapefruit because you
said why sorry these are your rules yeah
but if I had a face like a head like a
grapefruit then I only limited amount of
brains sure you know yeah you can expand
it more right be pretty dumb I like that
like dumber than this which is crazy
real quick you just say we mentioned
Michael Keaton do you do you do Michael
Keaton impression why exactly would I
this is Michael key just like our would
you rather it's kind of shameless yeah
would you rather fight a hundred
duck-sized horses or one horse-sized
duck to let you have the hug this will
last one
a hundred a hundred duck-sized horses
would I rather fight them yep or one
horse-sized duck we need some context
what's the nature of our beef mmm
you have stolen the bread and ducks were
going on okay yeah that's pretty good
I'm gonna go with the horse sized duck
oh yeah it's kind of freaky I like that
but there was no y so I'm not gonna all
right before we wrap up here we have one
more fan question okay oh and
buranovskiye he aged five he asks do you
have any helpers in the movie wyldstyle
or Robin yes
Owen is his name yes sir Owen Owen Owen
I I do have a great helper and his name
is Robin and I think you're like him
he's pretty
he's pretty fantastic that's awesome
awesome so much fun having you here
thank you so much and you guys everybody
on Fandango make sure you are watching
all of our Comic Con coverage from the
Fandango studio right everywhere all
aspects of social media on Fandango find
it we'll have more great interviews and
thank you so much will for joining us my
pleasure to be here